the culture wars the the wokeness wars
May in fact just be kind of a
distraction from those more fundamental
issues it's a point that uh your friend
Peter Thiel recently made on Barry
Weiss's podcast I want to play that clip
real quick and get your reaction to uh
teal statement as you know another
fellow Floridian
the focus on identity Politics on the
woke religion you know is probably a
distraction from stagnation it's a
distraction from economics it's a
distraction from the way in which uh the
younger generation the U.S uh is
probably going to have a hard time
having as a good standard of living as
their parents and so there's a set of
issues we do not want to talk about you
know I think DeSantis would make a
terrific president if he's the
Republican nominee I will strongly
support him in 2024 but I I do worry
that uh focusing on on the woke issue as
ground zero is is not quite enough
so I mean I agree pretty much with Peter
Thiel that while there's aspects of
these culture wars that are important
and worth discussing that they shouldn't
really be Central and we've got bigger
fish to fry there's the lagging economic
growth inflation a lot flows from from
that but there's also the degradation of
our institutions and in some sense like
I was saying before what we really need
is a strict constitutionalist to kind of
restore the balance of powers uh no no
be very clear about where State action
ends and I'm not exactly sure that
DeSantis is that and maybe he's better
than the alternatives on offer at the
moment but uh I just think it's always
worth sticking to our principles and
pointing out how far short just about
every modern politician Falls otherwise
there's really no path towards something
better if we don't kind of keep our eye
on the ball sure well first off I I just
think the scientist is your guy I think
you're going to begrudgingly I guess or
or maybe a little slower get there but
it just seems obvious to me I mean I
think you will find somebody that has an
absolute respect for the Constitution
and I you know some of the comments that
you read there Nick I mean people are
saying he's going after Free Speech or
saying like what can't you say in
Florida you can say whatever you want
okay
um specifically on Teal if he happens to
be a good friend of mine so let me not
hide that
um you know I believe that you I like
him a lot and I think he's a brilliant
thinker obviously but I believe that you
can walk and chew gum at the same time
and you can deal with the woke stuff
which by the way Zach when you deal with
the woke stuff you start fixing the
institutions because the institutions
you're worried about they're being
destroyed by woke they're being
destroyed by diversity equity and
inclusion so you can do that at the same
time you then can do all of the things
that have led Florida to be the freest
and most popular uh prosperous state in
the Union and and the proof is only in
the three-fingered pudding it's here
just look what's going on in Florida so
if you were to say to me well he's
focusing on woke so now look what's
happening Florida cities uh are being
overrun by drugs and homeless people
well then we might have an issue if or
or some other version but it's actually
all working here so I I think that that
argument is a little uh thin to me when
you just compare it with the facts on
the ground I just can't as the Zeal with
which you prosecute that war can often
the war on woke can often
cause you to engage and just really
gross State overreach in the ways we've
we've already talked about before I
guess we we just disagree on whether
that that constitutes State overreach um
it's the same thing with
um you know cleaning up crime or
cleaning or you know uh controlling the
Border these all these things all sound
good and orderly but there's ways that
if you don't have a strict Fidelity to
the rule of law that they can go
horribly bad and and authoritarian I
mean we didn't even really get a chance
to go much into immigration but some of
how that's played out here has been
alarming whether it's deporting people
to uh Martha's V or you know moving
people from Texas to Martha's Vineyard
or oh I think it's great I think it's
great
I find it reprehensible to be quiet
to use to use people as props like that
and the rhetoric around immigration I
you know this for me is one of the
biggest problems I have with the
Republican party and I and I don't
pretend that the Democratic party is
good on immigration but you know my
grandparents I'm I'm sitting I'm talking
to you from New York City where my
grandparents showed up a hundred years
ago uh they would not be allowed in the
country uh you know now and the anger at
immigrants is just wrong I think the
Republican party is making a huge
mistake by being so zealously
anti-immigrant but well first off I
don't think they're anti-immigrant I
think they are anti-immigrants
Donald Trump Donald Trump wanted to
reduce and he said it constantly I want
to reduce legal immigration as well as
illegal immigration Ron DeSantis is not
talking about legal immigration he's
talking only talks about immigration as
an illegal phenomenon and drugs are
being smuggled across the Mexican border
these that has nothing to do with
immigration policy it has to do with a
failure of immigration policy of letting
people who want to come here and
participate and contribute to American
life so and if we were if we're going to
want economic growth immigration is
going to be a big part of that so I
think there's just
um you know there some of the the focus
the focal points are just wrong at the
moment in from my point of view what
worries me about that fight that he has
against wokeness is that I'm not
convinced that he really is going to be
a defender of the Constitution you know
like when I moved to Florida I liked
that DeSantis swerved away from the
public health establishment so a lot of
what you're saying resonates with me
Dave I you know I like that he put a big
emphasis on letting individuals make
their own choices I think it was good
for the people living in Florida I think
it was good for the economy of Florida
what I don't like about the PO
desantises now he seems pretty willing
to use state power to advance a
conservative social agenda and punish
his enemies and I'm worried so what
would what would be an example of that I
assume you mean Disney right that's one
uh that that's a great example yes okay
so we should we should do the Disney
thing look Disney had
tons I've actually got a list of them
here because I had a feeling you were
going to ask me about them so I can read
them all off to you Disney because I
know this is an issue with Libertarians
that we should never use the government
for anything except what he did was use
the government in the exact way that
Libertarians want the government to be
used you don't want government overreach
but you do want to make sure there isn't
crony capitalism Disney took DeSantis
took special benefits away from Disney
meaning Disney had been granted special
benefits related to building codes and
water rights and this airport and taxes
and a whole bunch more I'm happy to read
them all off to you that were not
granted to their competitors such as Sea
World and Universal Studios and Gator
World which in essence do the same thing
they're they're theme parks so Disney he
then took their special rights away thus
evening the playing field which is to me
the ultimate thing that a Libertarian
would want you would want the government
only to act to even the playing field so
the the playing field was like this and
then he use the government to do this
there are thousands right or hundreds of
special tax districts in Florida that
were in place and remain in place he
also carved out in his social media law
he carved out an exception for Disney
before they crossed him on gay rights
um so it seems like it's La I mean part
of I you know and I'll let Zach speak
for himself but for me part of it is
that he is not acting out of principle
he's actually acting out of personal
Peak hey thanks for watching an excerpt
from our conversation with Dave Rubin
you can watch another excerpt from that
conversation right here or the full
conversation over here and tune in every
Thursday at 1pm for more conversations
like this